Speaker 1: This is just so weird, ridiculous,
radical, rancid and regressive.
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Bobber falsely
claimed the other day that the state of Texas
hasn't recorded even one covid death in more
than two months.
What the hell is she talking about?
Speaking to right wing commentator Gina Loudon
on Dr. Gina Primetime, Bouba ridiculed the
House mandate for mask wearing, said she enjoys
telling Speaker Nancy Pelosi to kiss her mask.
Clever, right?
Maybe English comprehension is suffering on
my end.
Maybe this is not actually what Lauren Bobert
is saying, but I've watched this three times
now.
It really sounds like Lauren.
Nobody's saying nobody in Texas has died of
covid since March 2nd when they pulled the
mask mandate.
Also, by the way, pay attention to her defiant
and principled opposition to everything that
public health experts are proposing.
But listen carefully here.
I think she's saying nobody in Texas died
of covid since March 2nd.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: You know, I'm really enjoying telling
Speaker Pelosi to kiss my mask, though.
Yesterday, Thomas Massie, Madison Cawthorn,
Brian Mast, Beth Van Duyne and several other
colleagues join me in refusing to wear a mask
on the House floor.
Thomas Massie and I both got warnings and
both of our letters ended up in the same exact
place.
Ironically, the trash left won't even listen
to the bureaucratic the bureaucrats at the
CDC.
And it just goes to show that this parties
follow the science slogan is a total joke,
just like this entire administration, just
like the entire Democrat Party.
They want to tell you to listen to science
and listen to data and facts.
But they haven't done that for more than a
year.
Too weak to slow the spread turned into communism
really, really quickly.
Now it's show me your papers.
But don't forget, Gina, Texas removed their
mask mandates two months ago and Sleepy Joe
called it Neanderthal thinking.
No, sir.
Republicans are just following the science.
And since removing the mask mandates two months
ago, Texas has not reported a single covid
death, not one.
Speaker 1: She said it.
She is saying that in Texas there has not
been a single covid death since they pulled
their mask mandate.
Now, unfortunately, the truth is 3600 Texans
have died of covid since March 2nd.
March 2nd is the day restrictions were lifted.
In the graph we're showing you, March 2nd
is where the Red Arrow is pointing.
And as you can see, numbers far greater than
zero every single day since that day.
So what could she even have meant by by this?
Does Lauren Bobert know that this is a lie?
But she's counting on viewers of this bizarre
show, not knowing that it's a lie, not knowing
it obviously doesn't pass the sniff test and
not fact checking.
It does.
Lauren Bobert herself somehow actually think
nobody died of covid in Texas since March
2nd.
The test in twenty twenty two is going to
be does Lauren Bobert get reelected or does
she get removed from Congress?
This is a really anti-American person.
Remember that Lauren Bobert back in December
tweeted Save the date, January six.
Twenty twenty one.
We know how January 6th turned out.
We know that Lauren Bobert gave guided tours
of the Capitol right before the January 6th
insurrection, even though the policy at the
time was no guided tours of the Capitol.
We know that Lauren Bobber tried to use the
recent Boulder, Colorado mass shooting to
say that we need more guns in more places,
which is just the idea she came in with.
She'll use anything to justify more guns in
more places.
And this is a truly you know, the the right
loves to claim for themselves the privilege
or rights or ownership of what is patriotism
and what does it mean to be for the United
States of America.
But some of these people are truly the most
anti-American people that you will meet in
terms of principles, in terms of their perspective
on what it actually means to abide by the
Constitution and to provide people due process
and access to all of the things which they
are entitled to through the Constitution and
the Bill of Rights.
This is a disgusting, disgusting person.
And if she gets reelected in twenty twenty
two, if Marjorie Taylor Green gets reelected
in 2022, if Madison Cawthorn gets reelected
in twenty twenty two, it will really ingrain
that this is the party of Trump and this is
the party that has abandoned what we're already
pretty bad principles.
I mean, let's be let's be pretty frank.
It's not like the Republican Party was a great
thing under Reagan, under McCain, Romney,
et cetera, but it was better than what they
have right now.
And they have a choice to make now and they
will get to make it in, what is it?
Eighteen months where eighteen months from
the midterm elections, do they say, yeah,
this is what we want more of Lauren Bobert,
Marjorie Taylor, Green, Cawthorn, the whole
lot of them.
Or will they say there has to be some limit
to this?
I don't know the answer to that, but we will
have more on this and other stories from today's
show on our Instagram.
Find us The David Pakman Show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
I've been getting some really wacky hate mail
lately, and I posted one of.
My Instagram David Pakman, let me know
what
you think.